by the way on Friday it's the Jim Nantz
and personation contest it's a tradition
unlike any other and the competition is
so stiff
Jim Nantz did not win last year that's
how tough it is the real Jim Nance
joining us now from CBS hi Jim how are
you today hello my friend I wish I could
enter that contest you know last year I
ran into one of the caddies out here on
the tour and he Gurley came up to tell
me that he had won this thing either
last year the year before so good luck
everybody how's the voice the voice
honestly I pulled a vocal cord on Monday
night at the end of a are you day today
no I'm fine I'm listed as probable your
syllable is syllable right now but you
pulled a volt vocal cord no I just you
know I'm still a little raspy this
happens I just called 15 games in 23
days and then when you have an
atmosphere like Monday night with a shot
by Markus page followed by of course the
epic game-winning shot you know you do
stretch your vocal cords so that just
happens anybody that's gone through a
lot of those kind of appearances
back-to-back and they know what I mean
it's just you know I'm just trying to
rest the voice a little bit and and it's
good to be down here I guess let us know
what it's like you know our people who
was spire to do play-by-play page hits
that shot now you have to put everything
into perspective
regroup yourself there's still time left
and then you know you know you're gonna
have to call something that's going to
go probably at the buzzer so how do you
compartmentalize that after Paige hits
the double double clutch well I haven't
gone back to look at it but here's what
I remember because it's all a bit of a
blur but when he hit the shot was such a
circus shot acrobatic and we're going
through a beautiful replay sequence from
our great producer Marc wolf and I think
you know there was a certain point where
we needed to look ahead now instead of
looking back because there were four
point seven seconds to go so you know
really grant and raft were going through
the replay sequence I made a comment
about Marcus's shot
there's gonna be a still photo one day
of him releasing that in midair that's
canola just unbelievable and I've
already seen that image by the way and
it is it's remarkable what that kid
didn't want us what a five-star person
Marcus pages anyway we regrouped I asked
the guy has now set it up here what's
going to happen and they did a really
good job of really foreshadowing a
foreshadowing what was about to happen
and you know they clear it out at that
point because it was going to be a link
to the court situation here and it came
in to Archie diak I know and I just I
mentioned once he got the midcourt he'd
gotten there at 3:00 grant then blurted
out he saw the Jenkins was trailing and
not guarded and was going to be open so
preaching on his part and then you know
got into Chris Jenkins hands and it just
you took at that point you just kind of
go with whatever it feels like at the
moment and I you know as a shot was
released I said you know for the
championship and boom he buried it and
you know the fireworks going off and
you're just it's a frenzy and of course
raff gets in his double onions sauteed
and it was a fantastic thing to be a
part of when did you begin the tradition
of giving out your tie to a senior I
know this has become like a viral thing
of course everybody's got a weigh-in and
have all kinds of nasty opinions about
it the reality is that given hundreds of
times away in my career I do it
virtually every single week the back
story is when I was a kid and I was
lucky enough to get a ticket to say the
NIT or a golf tournament I would run
around trying to get a close-up view of
the announcers I can remember seeing Pat
Summerall when I was little in donk
Rickey and then try to get close enough
just to look at these men these voices
that were part of my youth and hang out
under the towers at golf tournaments
just seeing if I could faintly hear him
you know from down below and I always
thought man if I ever get in this
position someday and I get to you know
meet some kids I want to give something
back so I gave at Iowa every broadcast
that I do and it's just not some random
guy what inevitably happens is a father
and a son will come over when I climb
out of the 18th tower or walk out of the
football booth or they'll walk away from
the basketball table and they'll be
standing there and asked for a picture
I'm not saying it's hundreds of
thousands of people but invariably there
is someone there
and I see a young man and I see that
father-son experience being shared and I
give the kid I give the kid my time it
happened Saturday victim had a kid in
Houston who I had given a tie two years
ago and he came up with his father at
the Final Four all these years later and
he said when he's a young boy I gave him
that tie he's getting married in that
tie soon in fact in the coming months
and he designed a logo for this year's
final four I don't know how years ago so
the tradition of giving it to a player
who really began
well after I started doing this he's um
I just I just thought you spent a lot of
time with these kids you find out what
quality people they are and I don't
believe I began it until I gave it to
Corey Brewer I was just so struck by his
story where he had come from and what a
fine young man he was and I gave him my
tie and I just you know thank them for
the time he had given me and by the way
if they don't want it you know it's okay
but no one's ever turned it away I just
I do it as a gift and an expression of
appreciation so through these last 10
years or so you know it's been something
that's been done very quietly
unfortunately there's media around
course people seize the moment to go
into high cynical gear and and and and
make fun of something that it's kind of
a fun moment that really is a reflection
of something I do every week to a young
kid you know that's there with a parent
and this year I gave it to Ryan Archie
diak I know didn't force Anonymous some
somebody decided they wanted to make it
sound like I forced it onto me in fact
you know I didn't tell him go wear it to
the press conference I didn't tell them
we're in the locker room but he's just a
great guy and Quinn cook got it last
year and you know through the years have
been some really great guys Mario
Chalmers and and and it's usually done
in a very private moment just go up and
say hey thanks and this year when I gave
it to arch somebody said hey what was
that all about and you know I should
have just said you know I borrowed a sty
or something but I was really really
happy to keep the tradition going he's
Jim Nantz from CBS joining a stand
Patrick show well let's go from that
viral
to the picture a picture of the burnt
toast that you carry in your wallet yeah
toast gate this is this has been
actually kind of fun
because you know I've now been
officially labeled as a weirdo so
there's something about that for some
reason I kind of like you know people
think I'm so predictable
but those who know me love that and know
that I love to have a little bit of fun
the whole toast thing is is is something
that is done as a is the ultimate gag I
do like my toast well done I'm not gonna
lie I don't have to have a charred
beyond recognition
I don't need dental records for my toast
when it comes to the table I just I do
like it well done so Lance Barrow who's
our producer writer for the NFL and for
the Masters on all of our golf you know
we're on the road a lot together and we
always try to one-up one another when
you're ordering breakfast about how
severely toasted you want your bread so
in that that was kind of the impetus for
me to eventually end up with a picture a
laminated picture of toast in my wallet
and and the fun part of it really is you
put it in the hands of a server and they
look at you like you're just gone crazy
and they laugh they take it back to the
kitchen because you say hey just tell
the chef's something like this and
you're really just kind of having some
fun with somebody at that time
invariably Dan the chef comes out of the
kitchen to see okay now who is this
crazy person it's in a restaurant and
you say hello and you know they bring
the toast out just the way you like it
makes perfect sense to me you know what
it is hit though like this this this
whole toast gate is like all of a sudden
everybody has an opinion about how they
like the special order that's really
what it is it's just a derivative of how
everybody today when they sit down at a
restaurant they don't just order it the
way it's on on the menu you know
everybody's got their own way of going
about making a hamburger or having their
steak prepared or what they want on the
side and okay so I have a bit of a toast
fetish but really more than anything has
done ingest its seen this better than
talking to masters I came actually in
right now if you notice the voice is a
bit dropped I
in Butler cabin having this discussion
with you about toast can we get a
picture of you in Butler cabin that we
can put on the show just jack jack
nicklaus sent us a picture earlier this
morning of of him at Augusta and honey
will you take a picture dan Patrick
doesn't believe that I'm in Butler cabin
right now talking about it and could you
hold up the picture of burnt toast Jim I
do have that on it's right behind the
picture of my children of course it is
of course it is of course it is all
right so hold up at oh hello toast hold
up the toast
you understand this is all in jest okay
of course I yeah as soon as I put it up
and then people start ripping you I'll
be right there with him like man that
Jim Nantz a weirdo I think we better
frame it this way this might be better
I'll leave that part Jim in Jim's
producing here now interacting and
producing from Butler cabin make just
the wall here okay now they'll never do
I think we got it I think we captured
the moment here now they'll never do a
real fire yet go ahead we're on the air
live he's live from public polling oh we
got somebody yeah the photo bombed us so
okay oh come on let's just end this one
okay send this right here we go ready I
don't know how we do you give out the
number no no you Frenchie we'll get it
you know French you'll get it when we
hang up saliva moan okay okay yeah there
is by the way well I'm not sure the
picture of the toast is showing up real
clearly here so we have some issues you
care to talk about the golf tournament
if jordan Spieth goes back to back what
would that mean to you to me you know
what will it mean to the game of golf
well yeah Golf well hey it's an exciting
time for the game Dan I mean it's just a
tremendous time for the game and he's
obviously going to be a part
of the top of the sport here for a long
time he's just a young kid still and how
he backed up the Masters last year with
his win at the US Open and then of
course end of the year with the Tour
Championship on the line and he kind of
was out at that point his game wasn't as
sharp as Jason days and he won that he's
just a he's a gifted player but you know
you're coming in here with storylines
that are just all over the place
you've got Jason Day now is number one
in the world you got Rory McIlroy which
I really like this pick this week
because you're you're not asking me
about Rory McIlroy no one is and he's
going for the career grand slam and this
is how I think you know you win these
things is when you come in people aren't
like wearing out with with constant
questioning about trying to become the
sixth player in history to win the
career Grand Slam well lo and behold
he's gonna be there and he he hasn't
closed the deal on a lot of tournaments
here in recent weeks but he's been he's
been in the neighborhood and he's a he's
a better player than just being in the
neighborhood and and I think this could
be a really great way for Rory
Dustin Johnson we're still waiting for
him to win her first major how about
butters of the support number by then
well lastly and you're reading my mind
here my man Bubba's won this tournament
two of the last four years and nobody
talks about no you know no one and he's
won this thing making it look like it's
easy now no wonder he wanted a playoff
but he the point is the way he attacks
his golf course with his length his
imagination he's truly easy he's a
creative genius you know and and if you
look at this way he visualizes shots and
figures it out there is a there's a
genius side to this guy and not a lot of
people know that much about him because
you know Bubba can be a quickie guy but
I mean I really think this guy is
borderline genius and I think he's got a
terrific chance of winning the third
green jacket before I let you go Jack
Nicklaus said that Tiger Woods was there
last night at the champions dinner
although I saw the picture I didn't see
Tiger in the picture do you know Tiger
wasn't able to take that one - yes yes
yes
we don't pay let me see if I can do that
yeah Ronnie let's go stairs take a
picture hey have fun great run fun and
I'm very excited about the competition
on Friday as you get these great
contestants across the country I know a
young man from Iowa won and a couple
years ago here's what you need to do
okay I got what you need you need to
close the loop here's what I need you
here's what I need knowing this guy who
wins it you need to start somehow
getting me the opportunity to meet these
guys the you know the winner you know
there's got to be some avenue for me to
have a phone number or something so I
can so I can send him a tie that's what
I was gonna ask you were thinking the
same as me my man
you would see a tie from Friday's show
Friday's broadcast will give out listen
how's that I will give him a future time
but I will no doubt be walking out of
the booth you're giving it away to some
young kid here on site but we'll work
something out I promise you so it's had
to be named later from Jim Nantz will
give will give a tie away you know
sometimes by the way just to qualify
here I've scurry out of the booth on
some of these football games to catch a
flight and there have been you know
there have been some shows where I
haven't given a thigh away but virtually
every show we're done all right
well that we will tell them a tie to be
named later from Jim Nantz and maybe a
phone call just as a congratulation
utley honestly I would get I would I
would I need to know these people I
don't need a kid it's a caddy on the
tour to come up and blindside me and
tell me that they won the contest I need
to know who they are
and I'm serious awesome all right we'll
put you on hold for a second fritzy will
give you a number to send the picture up
with the burnt toast from Butler cabin
okay thank you have a great week yeah
buddy we'll be we'll be watching that's
Jim Nantz the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience